Klasyczna optymalizacja to kluczowy krok w klasyczno-kwantowych algorytmach
takich jak wariacyjny solver własny lub kwantowe uczenie maszynowe.
Jednak często okazuje się, że trudno jest minimalizować
skomplikowane funkcje w przestrzeniach parametrów o wysokiej wymiarowości.
Mam na imię Victoria Lipinska i w tym filmie przyjrzymy się
klasycznym rutynom optymalizacyjnym dla klasyczno-kwantowych algorytmów.
Problemy optymalizacyjne nie są łatwe.
Gdy liczba parametrów rośnie, rośnie też liczba możliwych
kombinacji wartości — i rośnie wykładniczo.
W szachach na przykład jest 64 pola
i każdy gracz ma 16 figur — po tym, jak każdy gracz wykona jeden ruch,
mamy 400 różnych pozycji. Po dwóch ruchach 72 084 pozycje,
około 9 milionów po trzech i około
280 miliardów po czterech ruchach.
Jeśli dojdziemy tylko do 40 ruchów, liczba możliwych pozycji
szacuje się na około dziesięć do potęgi 120.
Rozegranie idealnej partii wymagałoby przejrzenia wszystkich możliwych
pozycji, a ten ogromny wzrost oznacza, że przejście przez
wszystkie pozycje po kolei jest niewykonalne.
Można to rozwiązać, dzieląc problem na dwa mniejsze podproblemy.
Po pierwsze, musimy określić, które układy szachownicy
mają szansę pojawić się w kolejnych krokach naszej gry.
Nazwiemy to naszą podprzestrzenią zainteresowania.
A po drugie, mając tę podprzestrzeń, musimy określić, jaki ruch jest najlepszy.
Nazwiemy to naszym najlepszym ruchem.
W tej analogii wstępne przeszukiwanie podprzestrzeni zainteresowania
odpowiada naszemu klasycznemu algorytmowi optymalizacyjnemu.
Gdy ta podprzestrzeń zainteresowania jest już znana,
kwantowy algorytm zazwyczaj odpowiada za znalezienie najlepszego ruchu,
mając tę podprzestrzeń.
Zacznijmy od rozważenia tylko jednego parametru,
theta, parametryzującego funkcję kosztu, którą chcemy zoptymalizować.
Jeśli narysujemy tę funkcję, powiedzmy że wygląda mniej więcej tak,
na osi X mamy wartości parametru theta,
a na osi Y jest funkcja kosztu.
Pamiętaj, że funkcja kosztu może być faktycznym kosztem finansowym,
który chcemy minimalizować, albo — jak to często bywa w wariacyjnym
solverze własnym — może to być energia minimalizowana przez naturę.
Naszym celem jest znalezienie takiej wartości theta,
która odpowiada najniższemu kosztowi.
Zaczynamy od początkowej wartości theta i w każdym kroku optymalizacji
wyznaczamy nową wartość theta, która jeszcze bardziej obniża koszt.
Wygląda na to, że dosyć łatwo wiadomo, w którą stronę iść na wykresie, jeśli możemy go zobaczyć.
Ale trudność optymalizacji polega na tym, że w rzeczywistości nie wiemy.
Dowiadujemy się tylko kosztu — czyli malutki fragment całej układanki —
gdy obliczamy funkcję dla wybranej wartości theta.
Na tym polega ogólna zasada działania optymalizacji.
Optymalizator próbkuje parametry theta i oblicza koszt.
Jak można się domyślić, losowe dobieranie parametru theta w celu odtworzenia
całej topologii funkcji nie jest zbyt efektywne.
Zamiast tego, mądre optymalizatory w każdym kroku
wyznaczają gradient funkcji.
Dzięki temu optymalizator wie, w którym kierunku na wykresie
podążać, żeby znaleźć najniższy koszt.
Gdy gradient wynosi zero, algorytm kończy działanie
i minimum zostaje znalezione.
To minimum może nie być minimum globalnym.
Może być minimum lokalnym,
czyli najmniejszą wartością funkcji kosztu w okolicy,
ale nie w całym zakresie theta.
W przypadku jednego parametru jak najbardziej jest to możliwe.
Jednak im więcej parametrów mamy,
tym bardziej skomplikowana staje się funkcja.
Już w przypadku dwóch parametrów mamy powierzchnię,
a przy czterech nie jesteśmy nawet w stanie jej narysować.
Tak jak w przykładzie z szachami, odtworzenie wszystkich możliwości
szybko staje się niewykonalne.
Widzimy, że trudno jest minimalizować
skomplikowane funkcje w przestrzeniach parametrów o wysokiej wymiarowości.
Jednak żeby uzyskać sensowne wyniki, chcemy, by klasyczna optymalizacja
była zarówno szybka, jak i dokładna.
Musi też być odporna na szum,
który będzie miał istotny wpływ w komputerach kwantowych bliskiej perspektywy.
Klasyczne algorytmy optymalizacyjne można ogólnie podzielić
na dwie klasy — metody przeszukiwania bezpośredniego i metody gradientowe.
Metody gradientowe wymagają informacji o gradiencie
funkcji w trakcie procesu optymalizacji.
Można go wyznaczyć analitycznie
lub przybliżyć za pomocą obliczeń różnic skończonych.
Metody przeszukiwania bezpośredniego nie korzystają z informacji o gradiencie
i stosują inne strategie, żeby minimalizować funkcję kosztu.
Do najczęściej używanych algorytmów optymalizacyjnych
w środowisku obliczeń kwantowych należą następujące optymalizatory.
COBYLA to skrót od constrained optimization by linear approximation
i jest to algorytm optymalizacyjny bez gradientu.
SLSQP to sequential least squares programming,
gradientowy algorytm optymalizacyjny.
Używa stochastycznego wektora perturbacji,
żeby jednocześnie wyznaczyć przybliżony gradient funkcji kosztu.
W środowisku bez szumów optymalizatory takie jak COBYLA
i SLSQP okazały się zbiegać szybciej niż SPSA.
Klasyczne optymalizatory mają własne parametry,
które możesz określić dla konkretnych przypadków, na przykład rozmiar kroku.
Zazwyczaj można je znaleźć w dokumentacji dotyczącej
konkretnego optymalizatora.
Zachęcam do sprawdzenia listy odnośników poniżej, żeby porównać
najbardziej aktualne klasyczne optymalizatory.
Przyjrzyjmy się jeszcze jednemu zjawisku związanemu
z klasyczną optymalizacją parametryzowanych quantum circuits.
Jak widzieliśmy wcześniej, zanikający gradient funkcji kosztu może wskazywać,
że optymalizator trafił na plateau bez żadnych interesujących cech — tak zwane
"barren plateau".
Barren plateau może być wynikiem wielu czynników.
Gradient funkcji kosztu odpowiadający quantum circuit
z losowo zainicjalizowanymi parametrami
zanika wykładniczo do zera wraz z liczbą qubitów.
Dzieje się tak, ponieważ przestrzeń kwantowa eksplorowana przez optymalizator
staje się wykładniczo duża, gdy liczba qubitów rośnie.
Sposoby na poradzenie sobie z tym problemem obejmują zmniejszenie liczby parametrów
i tym samym wymiaru przestrzeni bazowej.
Inny sposób myślenia o źródle problemu barren plateau
to agnostyczna wobec problemu natura parametryzowanego circuit
konfrontowana z wykładniczo dużą przestrzenią parametrów.
Zaprojektowanie circuit w sposób dostosowany do rozważanego
problemu może być dobrym rozwiązaniem.
Oprócz wykładniczej przestrzeni parametrów, która wywołuje barren plateaus,
inne zjawiska fizyczne mogą je również generować:
szum i dekoherencja obecne w eksperymentach z obliczeniami kwantowymi,
ogólna ekspresywność parametryzowanego circuit,
czy nielokalność i stopień splątania modelowanej funkcji kosztu.
Sprostanie tym wyzwaniom pozostaje aktywnym obszarem badań.
Po przeglądzie głównych składowych VQE,
podsumujemy algorytm w następnym filmie.